- Voici le début d'un voyage
intérieur pour Victor Pilon,
qui reprend à sa façon le mythe
de Sisyphe en déplaçant
du sable sept heures par jour,
six jours par semaine
et pendant un mois.
VICTOR PILON,
artiste multidisciplinaire
- Sisyphe représente aussi
le passage du temps, l'éternel
recommencement.
- Dans la mythologie grecque,
Sisyphe est un homme qui a défié
les dieux. Il a donc été
condamné à faire un travail
absurde : pousser une pierre
jusqu'en haut d'une colline
sans jamais y parvenir parce que
cette pierre va redescendre
malgré tous ses efforts.
Sisyphe est obligé de vivre
le moment présent.
- Je vais réfléchir, je vais
penser aux gens que j'aime,
aux amis, aux gens que
j'ai perdu, particulièrement
mon conjoint, qui est décédé.
Cette oeuvre là est un peu
un ultime hommage à Sylvain.
- Le mythe de Sisyphe
a profondément marqué
les intellectuels du 20e siècle
à cause de l'essai du même nom
de l'écrivain Albert Camus.
Face à l'absurité et face à
la mort, Camus avait pour seule
réponse la révolte et le combat.
- Albert Camus nous dit
qu'il faut vivre maintenant,
dans le moment présent..
Il ne faut pas vivre pour
un ailleurs. Il ne faut pas
vivre pour un ailleurs, il ne
faut pas vivre pour autre chose
que la vie présentement.
- Tout comme Albert Camus,
le conjoint de Victor Pilon
est décédé dans un accident
de voiture. Qu'aurais-dit
Sisyphe de tout cela?
- Albert Camus le dit si bien
qu'on doit l'imaginer heureux,
Sisyphe, et puis qu'il devient
un. Finalement, ce n'est plus
un châtiment. Il accepte son
sort. Une fois qu'on accepte
l'absurdité, on compose avec et
on essaie d'être créatif avec.
- Le public pourra assister
gratuitement à cette
performance-marathon,
qui a lieu au stade olympique,
un lieu symbolique.
MICHEL LABRECQUE, pdg,
Parc olympique
- À la limite, ce bâtiment-là,
qui est dénigré, tous les
Québécois et Québécoises,
on a investi, on a refait
une beauté à la tour, au centre
sportif. Donc il y a un effort
constant, même si on se disait :
bien pourquoi on ne jette pas
les gants! Bien non. Le
bâtiment, il nous dépasse. Il
est monumental, il est colossal.
- Nous sommes en quelque part
tous des Sisyphe et Victor Pilon
nous démontre qu'à travers nos
souffrances, il y a de lumière.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
--TRANSITION (OU